three consecutive american presidents
have enjoyed stints of explosive
economic growth due to a boom in oil and
natural gas production
as president would you be willing to
sacrifice some of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of blue-collar workers in the
interest of transitioning to that
greener economy the answer is yes
number one no more subsidies for fossil
fuel industry no more drilling on
federal lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends i've
never seen anything like putin's tax on
both food and gas
what up internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it's june 14
2022 we are live streaming on youtube
rumble blaze tv subscribe tap the
notification bell etc etc and before we
get going here today i said to my guys
right before we started i said what kind
of show are we going to do today what
level of show because i've been feeling
pretty good about the shows lately i
want to i want to be pressured you know
what i mean i want the pressure on game
seven of the nba finals i want the
pressure i said guys what level are we
talking about out of 10.
michael said we're going to do an 8.6
today
connor said in 8.7
and then foolishly phoenix said an 8.76
which was very specific
but using the price's right rules
he should have set a two right because
that way if i butcher the show he
automatically wins but if i do an eight
six show he's gonna lose so uh
interesting he's young he probably have
you ever seen prices right
you have seen prices right okay all
right fair enough anyway we got a big
show for you today because i think that
there's some good stuff happening while
these freaks and lunatics and crazy
people and conspiracy theorists run
around talking about january 6th and all
the racists who are coming to get us and
everything else
something has started to shift in the
ether there is something happening where
it's starting to go mainstream how bad
uh this elderly man pretending to be
president joe biden really is that he
told us he was gonna do a lot of the bad
stuff that he's doing right now hence
why we used that called open this
morning that he was telling us hey i'm
gonna crash the economy because i'm
going to go after the energy sector and
i don't care if it causes inflation and
i don't care how many people lose their
jobs and everything else and now
really this is finally in the last day
or two
democrats are starting to say there's
something not right with this guy maybe
he shouldn't run maybe he's not up to it
maybe he's not mentally and physically
there all of the stuff by the way that
the rest of us have been saying since
before the election but that's how the
mainstream media works right there's a
whole bunch of us we're called racists
and maniacs and conspiracy theorists and
alt-right we say the truth for a couple
years then finally it comes around to
mainstream media bill maher says it gets
on colbert then everyone else says it
and you know rinse and repeat so first
off i want to start today with this
incredible video that i saw yesterday on
twitter this is a spectacular
compilation of biden versus trump and
the predictions that trump was making if
joe biden was going to become president
take a look at this
before i took office there was a lot of
folks out there a lot of folks out there
making some pretty bold predictions
about how things would turn out
you might remember some of the
predictions
they're coming for your guns they're
coming for your jobs
and they're coming for your freedom they
hate american energy and joe biden will
shut it all down he's going to
uh that if
i became president biden's elected he
will wipe out your energy industry
another prediction
that is my favorite one i must add is
that if i got elected gas prices going
five six seven dollars for a gallon
flood your communities with criminal
aliens drugs and crime while they left
behind beautiful gated compounds
they try to take away your gun second
amendment they want to take it away
while they enjoy private security that's
fully armed i never understood that one
you spent trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders so for all those
predictions of doom and gloom six months
in
here's where we stand do you want to use
the word recession or depression think
of the single mom
strongly put food on the table each
month
you know it's sad so if your primary
concern right now is inflation we could
stop it in
30 minutes when i took office he finally
went outside he went to get an ice cream
look the bottom line is this i say
you're not doing a very good job because
he can't take any questions now from the
press
[Music]
how good is that
how freaking good is that and that's why
memes are now more powerful
than the mainstream media that really is
it right there you know how i've been
saying over the last couple weeks like i
don't need to always give you the stats
i don't need to always show you the
polls on the economies better this
number went down or the other thing i do
it sometimes i'm going to do it a little
bit today i think there is some reason
to know some of the real tangible
numbers related to inflation and gas
prices of course these things are
important but so much of it you can see
right in front of yourself and that's
why memes work because everything there
that trump predicted before related to
the energy sector related to guns the
whole thing it's all happening right now
and when the meme makers are out there
doing things like that that video it had
about five thousand views i was one of
the first people to catch it and i i
shared it it's got about three million
views right now that means three million
people saw that and they they see the
truth around it they see the truth
around it and they see that
man maybe some of us who thought that
donald trump was a better choice
than joe biden maybe we weren't crazy
maybe we weren't racists maybe it wasn't
because we hated america and we were
right-wing fascists but it was because
we saw
a somewhat flawed but competent guy that
had a pretty good four-year run despite
the entire machine trying to destroy him
versus a guy that was telling us what he
was going to do and now we have it all
right in front of us so that is the
theme of the show today that the stuff
that we've been talking about that you
guys know the incompetency of biden the
ridiculousness of this administration
whether they're doing it intentionally
or because they're incompetent whatever
the combination of that might be it is
starting to go mainstream and that is
good that is good that means
maybe
the thing that we're all trying to build
which is a restoration of america
a fight and a defense for capitalism for
freedom for individual rights all of
that stuff uh maybe it's on the horizon
again the old stuff might be on the
horizon how about that uh before i get
into any of that guys i want to talk to
you about bonner private wine because
you probably need a drink thanks to joe
biden's economy do you know what's going
on in that wine bottle sitting on your
kitchen counter no traditional media
won't tell you try oak flavoring mega
purple dye and tons of sugar and that's
not counting all the chemicals left over
from vineyards that look more like oil
refineries than the great shadows of old
but better wines do exist and they don't
cost an arm and a leg either take it
from america's top wine explorer
recently he came across a wine unlike
anything he's ever tasted
problem is this delicious red wine can
only be found in a single isolated
corridor known as the world's most
remote wine valley heck he nearly died
twice trying to find these vineyards the
wine is that special want to give them a
try head on over to bonner private wines
and my audience can get these rare wines
at half the retail price no need for a
promo code plus you'll get 50 off
shipping the wine is truly something
special supplies are limited visit
bonner privatewines.com
dave to claim your wine that's bonner
privatewines.com
dave i've got a bottle of the malbec
right here it is quite delicious so
there you go all right so let's continue
talking about the elderly man pretending
to be president and what he has wrought
on america things are not going
particularly well now there also has
been this silly january 6th hearing we
had 18 impeachments remember there was
an impeachment because he served that
football team mcdonald's then there was
an impeachment because he walked down a
ramp slowly there was an impeachment
because he drank water with two hands
there was an impeachment because he had
two scoops of ice cream and everyone
else had one there was an impeachment
because he had steak well done with
ketchup etc etc now they're having this
ridiculous january sixth hearing after
nothing happened with the impeachments
nothing's gonna happen with this thing
but it keeps a certain amount of people
in a state of lunacy and that's what the
media needs
so this
talking about numbers uh here is from
rnc research this is a google trends
map and what google trends shows is what
people are searching basically so from
rnc research here is a google trends
comparison for searches over the last
four hours on the topics of january 6
blue and gasoline red this tells you
all you need to know so it's one of
those things where we all know it
nobody nobody that is a serious person
no one that wants america to do well and
not be caught in the past and all that
stuff is paying attention to the january
6th thing it is a series of progressive
whack jobs and leftist socialist nut
bags and a bunch of people who can't get
over that that trump thing ever happened
they would gladly tank the economy
remember bill maher he wanted the
economy to tank to get rid of donald
trump well congratulations you got rid
of donald trump and joe biden the guy
you supported uh tanked the economy uh
but that trend right there that google
trend of what people really care about
do they care about january 6 well
nobody's really searching about that
despite the media pushing the hell out
of it and what do people really care
about well they actually
care about
gas prices we got a little bit more on
the economy from rnc research breaking
the dow jones industrial average nasdaq
and s p 500 are now lower
when than when joe biden took office
well we found video of just a few months
ago joe biden was very excited about the
stock market the stock market
the last guy's measure of everything
is about 20 higher
than it was when my predecessor was
there
it has hit record after record after
record on my watch well hot diggity dog
joe it was doing well a couple months
ago then yeah you know exacerbated this
situation with russia and ukraine and i
blame putin i stubbed my toe on the way
into the studio today i blame putin for
that too uh
and now
that was january 22 so now about five
months later the whole freaking thing is
crashing here is peter ducey of fox news
as you know he is one of the few
journalists that i don't have to put air
quotes around when i say the world
journalist and he's doing just a bang-up
job at these white house press briefings
uh here he is talking to karine
jean-pierre she is the black lesbian who
replaced jen saki
about what's going on with this stock
market situation
president biden once bragged about the
stock market hitting record after record
after record on my watch how about now
meaning the stock market
all the gains from president biden's
time in office have been wiped out
so
as you know we're watching we're
watching closely
we know families are concerned about
inflation in the stock market that is
something that the president is is
really aware of and so look we face
global challenges we've talked about
this uh this is we're not the only
country dealing with what we're seeing
at the moment as it relates to inflation
a lot of that is thanks to the american
rescue plan which only democrats uh
voted for that republicans did not and
it led to uh this this economic boom
that this historic economic boom that
we're seeing with john historic
inflation
no that is not that is that is that is
not uh
that is not how we're seeing the
american rescue plan
god you gotta love it guys they're
paying attention to it don't worry
families aren't concerned don't worry
and then the end of that is just so
absolutely perfect it's the democrats
who voted for the economic disastrous
thing that caused all of the inflation
or as she calls it an economic boom it
is their party that did all this and the
republicans who voted for it right so
this is completely bipartisan criticism
if you are a pathetic i don't i don't
know that i've ever said the phrase
rhino but if you are a rhino republican
and name only republican who voted for
the recovery and to basically demolish
the economy because that's what biden
and the democrats wanted this thing is
on you
too but what's the theme here that it's
starting to show it really is starting
to show and they are starting
to be unable to hide the fact that
things are not going well and it's
really getting pointed on the old man uh
here's more from rnc research
breaking biden's approval rating has
dropped below 40 for the first time
according to 538 now 538 like these are
basically lefties okay these are this is
basically a progressive polling
organization it's certainly a democrat
progressive polling organization it's
run by nate silver who is a lefty uh so
this is not like i'm going to some
republican polling thing and seeing if
they like biden or not this is the
simple fact that they cannot hide this
much more and uh now corinne jean-pierre
is being pressed on the fact that nobody
likes joe biden uh most presidents i'm
guessing would say don't pay attention
to the polls
um but does president biden feel any
concern that his approval rating is is
really pretty amazingly low and
consistently low
i believe today went under the average
140 first time the president's focus on
delivering for the american people
that's his focus right now
meaningless dribble
oh he's focused on that well is he
focused in the right way has he
you know maybe hired someone who's
competent who could help with the
economy instead of bringing on all these
social justice warriors and woke people
and trans activists to do other things
other than you know make things right
could he try any of that uh so then this
got peter ducey to follow up the natural
follow-up
[ __ ] ain't good so is the guy gonna
stick in this thing or what quickly is
the president running for re-election
he has ant
first of all
let's let's reset for a second i cannot
talk about elections i cannot be a
political analyst from here uh or uh you
know or the midterms or anything like
that or including 2024 the president as
you know has been asked that question
many times and he has answered it uh his
answer has been pretty simple which is
yes he's running for reelection i can't
say more than that all right so first
off i don't know what she's talking
about that she can't answer questions
like that she is the press secretary i
mean
you're the [ __ ] artist in chief
that's that's what it is that's what a
press secretary does whether you like a
press secretary or not a press secretary
is supposed to do the pr right the press
secretary is supposed to you know give
the best front forward facing facade
front forward facing facade to whatever
it is that you're doing on any given
topic so she can't talk about that then
she kind of muddles through it and then
yeah he's running he's running and it's
like we all know he's not running
everyone knows he's not running it will
be a miracle if he finishes this thing i
don't think he will and he's obviously
not running again everyone knows it i'll
get to that more in just a second but
what's happening here is a can of worms
is now being open the thing is bursting
into the mainstream that he's
incompetent that nobody really supports
him i mean any of you watching this i
get it you're not biden supporters
generally speaking if you're watching
this show but even the people that you
know that are roughly democrats like are
there people out there like old joe is
doing a great job i'm for biden i'm
proudly one of the 81 million people who
voted for joseph r biden you know what i
mean like something ain't right and they
can't hide it much more the media does a
hell of a job of always doing a shell
game january 6th etc etc but they can't
the can of worms is open pandora
pandora's box it's opening up and uh you
know you can do a little googling about
what happens when you open up a
pandora's box we'll get to that in just
a sec before i do i want to talk to you
about cozy earth i love cozy earth
hotter weather used to mean goodbye to a
good night's sleep until i discovered
cozy earth cozy earth's bedding is so
soft luxurious and temperature
regulating and i'm here in miami
that i'm sleeping better than i have in
years it's truly awesome and thousands
of customers agree with me like tiffany
i bought these sheets in part for
temperature regulation which it does but
i didn't expect them to be so incredibly
soft it's like sleeping on a cloud i
immediately bought a second set for when
it's time to change the sheets i'm
telling you it's that good people cozy
earth's sheets are made from the finest
luxury materials including soft viscous
from highly sustainable and ethically
produced bamboo and they're temperature
regulating so you can sleep cool and
comfy year round for a limited time save
35 on cozy earth betting check out their
awesome loungewear too go to
cozyearth.com dave and save 35 now all
backed by a hundred percent
a hundred night trial that's
cozyearth.com dave for 35 off okay so
where does this all lead as the can of
worms has been opened as pandora's box
is opening as democrats and media are
starting to talk about the fact that joe
biden is not well that the country is in
bad shape all of those things it's
starting to pilfer out mainstream can't
hold it much longer even don lemon over
on cnn he's starting to get it by god
he's getting it i can't believe it does
the president have the stamina
physically and mentally do you think to
continue on even after 2024. don you're
asking me this question oh my gosh he's
the president of the united states you
know he i can't even keep up with it we
just got back from new mexico we just
got back um from california uh that is
i
i
that is not a question that we should be
even asking just look at the work that
he does and look what he's how he's
delivering for the american public
grandpa's okay grandpa's okay sure he
pooped in his pants he doesn't know
where he is but don't ask us any
questions about that he's okay he's okay
well that response got her into a lot of
trouble because people watched that
response
which was obviously just sort of punting
it in the way she laughed it off and
it's like she knows everyone knows
that's what we all must do we must stop
participating in the lie we all know
something's wrong with joe biden it is
what it is i don't take any great joy in
that right he's the pilot of the plane
the united states is the plane i wish
the pilot was competent he ain't
but her muddled answer got her into even
more trouble so she put out this tweet
to be clear which is what they always
say to be clear as the president has
said repeatedly he plans to run in 2024.
so okay that's more pr nonsense it's
just more lying he is not running in
2024 as a matter of fact uh if you're in
the mainstream media and you watch the
reuben report by you know hosted by dave
rubin uh what i might recommend you do
is every time a well-known democrat is
out there let's say a hillary clinton or
a barack obama they should only be asked
one thing
will you support joe biden in 2024 and
let's see how honest they are because
they all know he ain't gonna run and
they know that they won't be supporting
him a because he's not gonna run but
they wouldn't support him anyway because
this whole thing is a complete
farce
but the other interesting piece of that
is if you flash back to the video that i
showed you a few minutes ago when peter
ducey asked her about joe biden running
she was said oh i'm not allowed to say
anything like that
then of course she puts out a tweet
saying just that so there's some
inconsistency there too okay so be it uh
let's go back to don lamont who i don't
know what's going on with don maybe
maybe what do you think happened maybe
he had some mushroom supplements or
something something's going on but don
at least had a moment or two of not
being horrifically awful
economists do cite the war in ukraine
and supply chain issues we did have that
before the war supply chain issues they
also say that last year's stimulus
package which you mentioned contributed
to inflation korean does the biden
administration bear some responsibility
for this
so first of all um
the american rescue plan met the moment
and it has put us in a place where we
can actually uh uh put us in a place
where the american people feel
can can actually we can take on
inflation and so that's really important
in order uh to take this on we got to
have some be in a good historic economic
place which is where we are right now
all right lemon look man
when you get one right i'll credit you
so good for you yes the right question
again she keeps saying the complete
reverse of the truth the american rescue
plan is it's something like you know
it's nothing she just says nothing but
it's sort of like oh this thing put us
in a place to kind of know what we're
doing so maybe we're going to get better
and things will be okay
i hope so
no the american rescue plan is what
added to the deficit it is what added to
inflation it was printing more money
that we don't have that has caused this
very problem but these people are all so
deep
they are so deep in the lies that they
don't know how to get out of it but if
you're shocked that cnn is going after
joe biden well then you're really
gonna i mean my god you're gonna freak
out right now because the mental
institution known as msnbc which they
televise 24 hours a day a 24 hour a day
mental institution uh they're going
after him too here's joe scarborough uh
and steve ratner and they're not happy
with joe biden anymore
exactly what happens and my god i just
wonder what would have happened if
progressives have gotten their six
trillion dollar wish earlier this year
yeah in an ironic way you almost have to
thank joe manchin for blocking that
because six and a half trillion dollars
of spending in this economy would make
these numbers look small yeah look we
had a we had a huge budget deficit by
the way i wouldn't even say ironically
thank joe manchin you can just thank joe
manchin
uh if
you're glad that interest rates aren't
even higher for the life of me
i can't figure out why they keep doing
this uh
you know going to the press
setting false deadlines
deadlines that are going to fail this is
pretty simple stuff let me say that
again
this
okay so this is wild and i want to say i
like when people who are wrong about
everything get things right right that's
why i'm always going on about bill maher
it's like you're wrong about a lot of
stuff then you get some stuff right i
want to get you there okay don lemon
you're wrong about everything
occasionally you're right i want to get
you there joe scarborough you're wrong
about everything you're right about
something occasionally i want to get you
there what's incredible about this is
msnbc everyone on msnbc everybody i'm
sure in those 87 boxes they just showed
you an iq combined of six
these people all of course push for the
american rescue plan which led to this
it led to this take a pen one starting
point one ending point
it gets us there okay you can't just
print money and then think nothing's
going to happen translatory inflation
and all of their made-up phrases okay
so i will credit them for now
occasionally having like you know some
synapse actually fires right a neuron
fires and holy cow something's happening
over there that's actually nice to see
but i said to my guys while we were
playing the clip i want to find
some clips of msnbc and joe scarborough
going after a mansion because there's no
doubt right what happened when this was
all being held up by scary joe manchin
and scary kirsten cinema they were white
supremacists they're republicans they're
mean they hate poor people all the usual
nonsense so we'll try to get a
compilation on that tomorrow of joe
scarborough saying the exact reverse
stuff about mansion and everything else
but okay congratulations scarborough you
got something right but it's not just
members of the media now
it is democrats full on
card carrying they get a laminated card
card carrion
democrats here is dnc committee member
uh
wait is this aaron burnett is that his
name or he's on the aaron burnett show
is his name aaron burnett i'll get back
to you in just a second on that but this
is a dnc committee member he's the chair
of the miami-dade democrat party uh
saying what biden should or should not
do what's your reason for i mean is that
your reason for not thinking you should
run again or is it just quite simply as
david axelrod said at the end of his
next term he'd be closer to 90 than 80.
uh you know what what is the reason
it's a host of factors the first being
that the approval rating is not where it
should be at this point
but also more importantly if you look at
the polls with regards to the direction
of the country less than a quarter of
americans think that our country is on
the right track with polls like that
people are going to be looking for a
change candidate they're not going to be
looking to vote for an incumbent with
approval ratings down in the 30s
okay to be clear in case you're confused
that was aaron burnett the host of the
cnn comedy program and steve simonides
is the head of the uh democrat party
here in miami-dade county and basically
he's out there saying uh this thing
ain't working now let's flash back all
the way to yesterday remember yesterday
it's pretty good day everything being
equal uh and aoc
was basically saying she is not going to
support biden right like we played the
clip we're going to play a little bit of
it for you right here uh and some of my
response i was on newsmax last night uh
recapping it and remember before i
always say they say let's be clear so
you'll see what i did here
but aoc ain't supporting him either and
the thing is bursting forth
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now
and preserving a majority this year in
2022 so we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it but um but i think if if the
president has a vision and that's
something certainly we're all willing to
entertain and examine when the when the
time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it okay
so no
well let's be clear i mean there is zero
chance that joe biden is running again
and i mean that zero quote me on this
click this thing and send it across the
internet there's no chance
send it across the internet people on
the computer machine the guy is not
running again obviously
yesterday he did an event and the press
started asking him questions and look
how fast this old man is when he has to
get moving
we're not going to ask any questions i'm
not going to answer anything i'm joe
biden he's fast when he needs to be fast
but what does this all mean what does
this all mean okay you get it biden's no
good the party's turning against him the
media is waking up uh well there was an
orange man and you may remember him he
was very popular a few years ago
then the internet decided to kick him
off
but he might come
back
back in the state where presidential
campaigns are born former president
trump rallying supporters and hinting at
a 2024 bid back to make america great
again
dash
slash comma again
make america great again again i don't
know
that's him at his best that's him at his
best when he's being silly and funny and
the whole thing what do the democrats
think about him coming back
do not come
do not come
i'm gonna come
oh
[Music]
that's some good work guys uh there's
another guy who might come his name is
ron desantis and he was in new york city
yesterday and of course they were
protesting him because he hates gays
blah blah blah
and on fox they tried to ask him about
his 2024 positioning
people really do appreciate if you're
willing to stand up and fight for them
man they'll walk over broken glass to
support you for sure i mean it's that's
the same mentality that when donald
trump said i could shoot someone on 6th
avenue because he went out and fought
for them so i'm going to try one more
time
if he runs in 22.
these are futile
these are few
opportunities you should see the movie
top gun it's amazing uh i'm genuinely
curious so if he runs do you run how do
you make that decision
nice try man we're uh we're here talking
having fun here so uh so it's all good
when will you announce or when will most
of the candidates announce not until
after midterms i have no idea i mean you
know at the end of the day i think the
interesting thing about me is people
always you know inject my name into it
just based off what i'm doing in florida
and so you know we've really
gotten more notoriety not because i'm
out trying to do that just because i'm
getting things done for people in my
state and so it's a little bit different
for me i mean i think there's obviously
people that the minute 2020 and have
been basically running and they're going
around doing all that stuff you know
that's just not been what i've been
doing i've just been focusing on the
task
isn't that such a refreshing answer and
and i said to my guys as we were playing
i think it's true like obviously i've
gotten to know him a little bit and i
had about 20 minutes alone in the green
room with him before the interview uh
you know 10 days ago or so and it's like
i didn't ask him the question that
everyone would want to ask because i
think that is the honest answer right
there he's like i'm just doing my job
and isn't it refreshing to just hear
someone just be like i'm doing my job
i'm a competent individual i can smile
about it and joke about it and all that
stuff but you know they keep mentioning
me it's only because i'm doing a good
job here he's also in the middle of his
own reelection here obviously and he's
going to crush it and then we'll see but
what this all leads to let's just put
aside incompetent bite and let's put
aside the ridiculous socialists and the
communists and all that there's an
incredible there's such
an incredible opportunity here for the
republicans to do something that would
be massive and get us all out of this
craziness we're all in this slow descent
to hell together right we are whether
you're a republican or a democrat or an
independent or
whatever you are we're all in this thing
together
and there is such an opportunity right
now for the republicans to do something
magical they're going to have to figure
this thing out the trump desantis thing
has to be figured out i have no insight
as i said to whether desantis even wants
to run it does seem like trump is going
to run
but you don't want them running against
each other is there a way they can work
this thing together that maybe trump's
the top of the ticket and desantis says
i'll be vp but in a much more expanded
vp role like i'm gonna staff everything
i'm gonna help guide the policies not
just the nonsense
that vps usually do and you know be pet
on the head every now and again like
kamala like not that but like could they
really come together and do this like
really do something completely game
changing
i don't know i don't know but i hope
they can figure this out because then we
could have the widest tent we could have
a truly pro-america
pro-freedom pro-individual rights
pro-reality party
led by
one guy who
trump is what he is but he is a freaking
fighter and he's willing to stand up to
the thing and another guy who also is a
fighter but is deeply deeply competent
and has done something magical
genuinely magical here in florida so i
hope they can figure it out guys stick
around for the cold close it's a good
one let me get to a couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com no autocrats
said do you think the brandon
administration will do anything to stop
the markets from bleeding
i don't know because as i keep saying i
sort of think this is what they want in
a weird way i don't think biden's in
charge i think he has a bunch of
completely incompetent people
surrounding him everyone around him is
completely incompetent they lied about
all of this inflation is transitory and
we've got our transportation secretary
who's gay he knows nothing about rhodes
and our trans this one like it's just a
clown show of woke insanity so i don't
know what they can do to turn this thing
around uh what i do think is that the
wokes the true worksters
and i'm not talking about biden here
nobody knows what biden is anything
anymore he's nothing biden's just like a
shell of a human but the true workstars
the squad and the aocs they are they are
freaking drooling right now they are
licking their chops knowing that this
disaster will wreck any semblance of the
old democratic party right now in my
hope it will lead to a very strong wide
tent republican party but they are going
this is our final moment of takeover
they have been eroding and destroying
the democrat brand for years this is
what they wanted
all the old democrats folded and they're
licking their chops they got the meat
right there and they're about to
uh clean up that's what they're gonna do
so that's where we're at uh mad for carr
says the dems take zero responsibility
for anything going on in the country it
is amazing how they turn their heads
yeah it's it really is amazing and their
and how their answers are just always
nothing i love how uh korean sean pierre
she's always flipping through papers you
know they're korean champion how are you
feeling this morning well i'm uh
oh i'm okay i'm okay it's just nothing
weekly cigar news says good morning from
miami well good morning from miami how
are you in miami oh speaking of miami by
the way all the vip tickets to the miami
show that i'm doing on july 14th they
sold out like immediately immediately so
we just opened up 50 more i will give 50
more hugs i'm willing to do it uh you
can go to daverubin.com events i'm at
the miami improv on july 14th with a
special guest which we'll probably
announce in the next couple days uh if
you'd like to chat during the show join
us at reubenreport.locals.com
part one of my interview with utah
senator mike lee he is on the short list
of sane people in the united states
government that's up right now the full
things up at locals and finally we've
got a cold close for you oh and by the
way guys
you said eight six today
you said eight seven
you said eight seven six i think this
was a 9.5 i felt very sharp today i felt
very
phoenix
congratulations
you're getting
you're getting extra guacamole all right
see you tomorrow guys
i don't know why they do this but they
only give me one pin
i used to stand an absolute
and watched barack obama
signed with seven eight nine different
pens barack obama